look we've heard it for years
Koreans are pretty good aliens score
deaf people to pick up graves in the bag
it's still a very close fight and score
gets even lower since barely to go down
death is really the MVP of this fight
though she takes out another still
trying to go up the key bow picks up a
triple kill after getting a server at
the end of 2011 the region won nearly
every International League of Legends
competition they showed us what true
dominance looks like and then they
scattered
welcome to Korean talk where all we talk
about it the Korean players in China
yeah yep this is pretty much our life
and so today we're going to be talking
about more Korean players as we will
probably next week after Samsung White's
world's victory in 2014
organizations all over the world made
bids to attract top Korean talent na and
EU teams made bids to be sure but more
than anyone else
Chinese organizations made huge offers
to Korean stars to get to to play in the
LPL during that off season both of
Samsung starting rosters will left the
region and they took some of Korea's top
talents with them like piglet and impact
it was absolutely monumental everything
changed if the rest of the world
couldn't keep up then it was time to buy
some Korean talent so when you think
about China coming out of the scene a
big piece of it is how are they gonna
get players to Chinese players were
alright at the time but everybody knew
that Korea had the best players and so
what was gonna send them over it
definitely was a lot of money I have the
time in Korea East where the team is
mostly acted as marketing arms for huge
corporations like SK Telecom and Samsung
their players wore their logos and since
eSports were already popular in Korea it
was a good way for these companies to
build their brands but those players
weren't the ones signing massive
blockbuster contracts and that was how
China and the rest of the world drew
those top players into places where he
thwarts wasn't as well built and they
started getting offers that you couldn't
imagine you would ever hear in Korea for
a salary plus sponsorships plus
streaming opportunities the world
champions disbanded for money and for
different opportunities instead of
marketing for companies these players
were signing contracts where they were
the main attraction they were going into
a market where eSports can be built
around that this was a year that set the
groundwork for massive outside
investment in eSports by the end of the
year we thought teams like echo fox and
immortals building league of legends
rosters and they all woke towards Korea
fans have the right to be scared
especially since you know we look at
past examples like a year up with
Starcraft where Koreans came in and
completely took over the Europeans
you think about that situation you say
do I really want my and ALCS like re
eSport do be dominated by Korean players
in North America we've all come to know
that twitch is the place to go to for
streaming but in China that's not the
case there are plenty of streaming
platforms that are analogous to twitch
and they're all competing for territory
and to do that they sponsored League of
Legends players at the time China was
awash in streaming money so there were a
bunch of competing streaming services
that were sponsoring teams they would
have all of this money to spend lavishly
on some of the best Korean players many
of the Korean players have made the move
to China signed a huge contract but the
included streaming obligations which
require them to stream on platforms like
Huia and o you who subsidized their
contracts of course it wasn't just
Chinese teams an important talent some
Korean players made the jump to the LCS
stage as well or stone by no booth with
cash America
hey Gong whoosh before we were done yogi
a hard cut to another to another nice
thing the cutting I get to a pool the
next year Korean players were just as
dominant as they'd ever been but they
were dominant in every region both North
America and Europe benefited from the
imported korean talent and of course
China added a ton of Korean talent that
they started to work into they're now
hybrid super teams I feel like this is
definitely the meta especially for death
and so even making that ranking for
who's the best bottom line I think I
would go for death because he has that
fun which he wants to play for the team
horn and deaf have looked amazing so far
almost strict upgrades yeah Poland deft
as you say almost strict upgrades that
definitely slotted in very well having
porn in the mid lane gives them some
engaged opportunities was of course the
previous mid laner was more of a wave
claiming a more of a safe liner porn
loves to pick up that fizz and play
aggressively they're getting picks from
that point all the while there are more
eyes on the game as a whole partially
because people wanted to see how the
whole Exodus would work out that said
there were some hiccups
it took roster some time to gel as
players found out it's pretty hard to
communicate on a team where not everyone
speaks the same language became clear
that winning games wasn't as
just putting a bunch of superstars on
the team that in mind
there were also victims and word gaming
made history with their counter pick
strategy that defeated SKT at MSI faker
has never lost with leblanc on the
competitive stage SK Telecom t1 are
wiped the Nexus turrets are going down
LPL's Edward gaming are the 2015
midseason Invitational champions or how
fnatic was able to make it to Worlds
semi-finals that same a year with the
addition of both Cooney and reignover
[Applause]
a few chips
but despite some flashes of brilliance
by the end of 2015 it seemed like the
exodus wasn't having the kind of
long-term impact the most these
organizations are hoping for we all
learned that it wasn't as simple as just
adding Talent players need to play well
together needed to communicate needed to
play as a team in order to win at the
highest level it did it temporarily pay
off for the Chinese teams so in the very
short term yes none of them really made
it work no player was successful in
maintaining a consistent lifestyle where
they could focus on the game the
language barrier proved to be a little
bit more difficult than they would have
liked the overwhelming prowess of Korean
League of Legends was slowly bleeding
into other regions but perhaps more
impressive than anything else that
happened that year was that Korea didn't
miss up let me make it up sentence Oh
the matter Kuro gets a kill anyway
steal the dragon
the fight over the wall come chill
Frisian as well
SK Telecom can they finish this enough
spec go deep making it double for
easyhoon some of the region brightest
stars left the country but their shoes
were immediately filled by some of the
best to ever play the game that year
showed us just how deep the Korean
talent who really is and of course 2015
marked the beginning of SKT is
devastating two year run were they won
nearly every tournament they participate
in it
Tigers are falling SKT your first-ever
two time
they turn their attention to the Nexus
SK Telecom
continued to rule the world and they are
your midseason Invitational champions
every challenge
but maybe what's also worth remembering
is what the year did to the game as a
whole
according to Riot Games world's
viewership increased from 288 million in
2014 to 334 million in 2015 and all of a
sudden investors were looking at League
of Legends franchises the same way they
look at traditional sports by 2017
many of the Korean players would left
for China returned home but there were
some success stories in storybook
fashion rookie waste the summoner's Cup
as Invictus gaming became the first
Chinese organization to become world
champions well vacation either today I
just heard offensive to say just look it
up fans today China to das a logical way
to telethon ocular visual feature gadget
Vancouver in some ways it helped with
the perfect ending the revolving door of
Korean exports over the last few years
for the guy who bought it hardest to his
new team learn to speak Mandarin and
built a career with IG this was proof
that work he made the right choice and
in the end he emerged victorious when
the dust settled on the great Korean
Exodus thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
you
[Music]